hey there guys so today I'd like to talk
to you about working memory I used to
think that working memory was the most
boring type of memory and the most
boring aspect of your cognitive ability
that you could enhance with the training
I have since reassessed that view I
think I was wrong I actually think that
working memory might be the single most
important aspect of your cognitive
ability that you can train I am entitled
to change my opinion
[Music]
so what is working memory let's start by
looking at the traditional view laid out
by Baddeley and hitch so they looked at
memory as a whole by separating it into
three different categories you have your
long-term memory short-term memory and
working memory not serving that order so
the long-term memory is where you store
your long-term memories let's present
your biographical information names of
old friends memories from school things
you've learned it set the stuff that
you're just not going to forget then
you've got your short-term memory and
that's where you store stuff that you're
using you know at the moment you can
retrieve it at will you have to think
about it all the time
however you might forget it in the
distant future so this might be the name
of a character in a film you're watching
it might be the name time you're
speaking to might be what you had for
dinner yesterday and then you've got
your working memories and this is
essentially ramp
according to babbling hitches model this
is the shortest term memory be the
memory that you use to hold numbers when
you're performing wrong multiplications
when you're carrying a number across if
someone reads the phone number to you
you use your working memory to a hearse
that number back to yourself so you can
remember it what to go and grab a pen
and write it down that's the example
that's constantly being used so
according to this traditional model you
would need something you'd have to
rehearse it and the more you repeated it
the more likely it would be to get
stored in short-term memory and then
with repeated use further it would get
stored in long-term memory we now know
that you can store memories for longer
also if they're very important you don't
just have to rehearse them is something
very important you release more dopamine
and adrenaline and needs help we see so
many memories more permanently by a
long-term potentiation training
flashbulb memory that's like you know
people if you experience something very
shocking you have to repeat that to
remember it's important to you the
emotions that really
you encode their long-term memory but
what we're interested in right now is
that working memory the RAM so according
to Baddeley and hitch this can also be
split down into multiple categories you
had your phone a logical leap which is
where you've stored words and things and
you had your visuospatial scratchpad
which is where you would visualize stuff
etc so the phonological loop is where
you would literally repeat the number to
yourself as you went to write it down
the visuospatial scratchpad is where you
would visualize things and there ways
you could train your working memory and
improve it
traditionally working memory was
measured by how many units of
information how many numbers you could
remember at any given time and this is
usually written as 7 plus or minus 2 so
someone with a really great working
memory can remember nine numbers song
with a pretty poor working memory can
remember spies the average is about
seven you can train this using various
different techniques for instance you
can use chunking which is essentially
like a way of compressing files for your
own brains so here catch the number five
numbers you would instead make it two
numbers so if you have to remember seven
threes I'm doing this off the top of my
head six nine two seven three six nine
two you could instead remember it as 73
692 I avoided the temptation of 69 there
the point being that you're now
remembering a couple of things instead
of lots of things I think this is the
first clues the battlin hitches model
isn't quite accurate because if you're
remembering something using a
phonological loop why the semantics
chunking make any difference I'm
surprised because this theory had as
much weight as it did so as long as it
did because really the brain doesn't
store things arbitrarily in neat little
boxes and categories in fact information
will often be cross-modal so more recent
research has revealed that working
memory is actually a lot more
interesting than just where you can
store numbers or the picture of
something you have to remember so
according to brain imaging studies when
you access your working memory what
you're actually doing is visualizing so
if you remember something in your
working memory
that is to do with something you've seen
you actually activate parts of the
visual cortex as though you were seeing
it when you use this phone logical link
you're actually activating your auditory
cortex as though you're listening to it
and when you remember numbers you're
actually stimulating the spade parts of
the brain steel stimulate when you're
crunching numbers in real time so really
working memory isn't Ram at all really
working memory is visualization once the
memory is your ability to internalize
information and to picture it in your
own mind and then by doing that you can
hold on to that information even though
it's not there in the real world anymore
you're concentrating on those vain areas
that you lift up either from an idea
that you have something you remember or
something you've seen or heard and this
makes working memory incredibly powerful
far beyond writing down phone numbers
five seven plus or minus two is is
meaningless because you're using working
memory when you're playing a sport and
remembering where everyone is on the
pitch at any given time to platitude
you're using your working memory when
you're in conversation and remembering
what the context of that conversation is
what people have said so far what you're
going to say back to them their names so
in just those two examples working
memory is making you with you it's
increasing a spatial awareness in your
athletic performance working memory is
also of course what you use for
multitasking there's no such thing as
multitasking really you can't separate
your consciousness into two part
probably that's probably something to
look at so what you're really doing is
called serial casting which is where you
just switch from one task to another and
in order to do that you need to be able
to hold information from the previous
task in your working memory which is a
anachronistic way of saying it as we've
discovered what you're really doing is
just visualizing using those same parts
of your brain what you're doing
concentrating on it so that you can
switch to another task and then switch
back and still have that information
available in your brain
these access and continue with that
other task so really every aspect of
your mental and your social and your
athletic performance relies on this
working memory on your ability to
internalize information into visualize
and if you watch my video on embodied
cognition you'll know that pops
all of human consciousness comes from
this ability for my ability to look at
our own bodies and our experience in the
world and use that to understand the
world around us so if you can enhance
your working memory you can enhance all
these skills this is the closest thing
you're going to get to a limiter style
upgrade so how do you do it
well outdated though some notions of
working memory might be you can still
use the old fashioned trading methods
they will still work so the most famous
one is the dual n-back test this is a
test that has you remembering two
different things at once and then
watching for patterns and seeing when
they reoccur you're basically just
practicing using your working memory
because you're holding that information
in your mind whilst trying not to be
distracted playing chess can also give
your working memories because what
you're doing is you're visualizing the
moves ahead and you're remembering all
the places on the board that you've
occupied ins your opponent's occupied
etcetera again it's all about holding
information in your brain it doesn't
have to be memories even it can be an
idea or future information today you
know what I mean and another one you can
use of course is the old pairs memory
game that you packed you to play with
your mum like say with my mum so maybe
you played it with your mum so matching
pairs of course require these to
remember where all the cards are and
what's on the bottom of them all and
that is using your working memory again
I thought gluten team we videos make you
look clever or something such as its
awkwardness but the most interesting and
the most powerful way to train your
working memory of course is with
meditation so studies show that working
memory colleagues a lot with your
ability to focus your attention the
bottleneck on your bilities usual
working memory is whether or not you can
focus on that and keep those areas of
the brain active all your going to be
distracted by other thoughts other
things going on around you which is a
bigger and bigger challenge
in today's modern world so meditation
has been shown in studies to boost your
IQ and specifically to boost your
working memory and this makes a lot of
sense because what meditation is really
is practice focus what you do when you
meditate if you practice on blocking out
distractions and focusing on your
breathing on a mantra on your Dan Tien
or just on nothingness so it's you
literally taking control over your mind
and deciding what you want to focus on
so of course it makes sense that this is
correlate with improved working memory
I've actually been looking into
meditation more more lately something
I'm definitely gonna cover on this
channel but I need to get more practice
in myself before I start giving advice
on it because I'm definitely very new to
it but the evidence can't be ignored
meditation is pretty much a huge mental
upgrade and yes so stay tuned for more
on that and of course for more on all of
the stuff that I tend to talk about so
brain training and trophic productivity
technology bodybuilding weight lifting
strength parkour martial art you name it
that sounds interesting then stay tuned
maybe subscribe if you'd like this video
then that would help me a great deal and
maybe you leave a comment down below
because I love discussing this stuff
with you guys thanks a ton for watching
and I'll see you in the next one bye for
now